alors que l'agencé européenne des
médicaments a rendu son verdict
concernant le vaccin astrazeneca et a
indiqué qu'il n'était pas dangereux pour
les populations voilà qu'une nouvelle
affaire bien faire frissonner le monde
une enquête a été ouverte à nantes après
le décès d'un étudiant il avait été
vacciné il ya quelques jours avec
astrazeneca
autant vendredi le premier ministre
castex avait décidé de se faire vacciner
devant les caméras par le vaccin
astrazeneca pour encourager les plus
sceptiques à faire de même
aujourd'hui la presse se fait l'écho
d'une nouvelle polémique autour du
vaccin
cette fois ci c'est un étudiant nantais
de 24 ans qui est décédée quelques jours
seulement après avoir reçu une injection
du vaccin étudiants en médecine élite
aujourd'hui encore trop tôt pour savoir
si astrazeneca est responsable ou non de
cette mort mais les causes du décès
pourraient correspondre à ce qu'on
reproche aux vaccins en effet le jeune
homme aurait été victime d'une
hémorragie interne causée par une
thrombose alors décès d'un jeune
vaccinale astrazeneca faut-il
s'inquiéter du vaccin
gérard de l'opi net avec no mercy
oncologues et chirurgie remercie d'être
là gérard merci à vous merci et martin
blachier épidémiologistes alors on l'a
vu on a eu cette triste nouvelle
aujourd'hui anthony un étudiant en 6e
année de médecine âgée de 24 ans a été
retrouvé mort dans son appartement à
nantes
inquiet de son silence les proches de la
famille ont alerté les pompiers ils
découvrent alors son corps dans son
logement verrouillée de l'intérieur
il venait de finir un examen blanc en
vue du concours déterminant les
affectations en internat de médecine et
ils avaient été vaccinés 8 mars dernier
au vaccin astrazeneca alors ce matin le
frère d'anthony kevin athée vernier
témoigné dans la presse régionale
il est persuadé que le décès de son
frère aîné au vaccin salle astrazeneca
mon intime conviction c'est que le
vaccin a déclenché la thrombine au la
thrombose qui a causé sa mort je veux
bien que l'on me dise tout ce que l'on
veut mais je vous mets au défi de
trouver une personne qui a une thrombose
à 24 ans c'est vrai ça ou pas non il ya
des personnes coincées rares saint ouen
non ça arrive ça arrive mais là
effectivement la sq il a eu six plus qu
une thrombose ans un phénomène de
coagulation très grave qui effectivement
est quelque chose de très rare chez des
personnes aussi jeune je dis pas que ça
n'a aucun lien avec le vaccin puisque
c'est des choses qui sont déjà arrivés
il ya quand même eu huit personnes en
allemagne effectivement à ces jeunes
qu'on lui des thromboses grave avec une
probabilité plus importante que ce qu'on
voit dans la population générale
essentiellement des gens qui sont jeunes
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que l'autorité
française enlevée les jeunes de
l'indication de ce vaccin non mais non
mais pas sans raison vous comprenez
certaines personnes qui comptent crois
qu'il voit le témoignage du frère
d'anthony quand il voit ce qui est
arrivé à anthony qui se disent anthony
il était en pleine santé il avait 24 ans
il a fait le vaccin
il ya beaucoup de gens
voilà et qui vont se dire je pense qu'on
va on va quand même pas y aller c'est
clair toute façon tous les gens qui ont
moins de 55 ans ils peuvent pas avoir le
vaccin astrazeneca proposé nord et avant
l'inter d'arrêter avant l'interview dans
la section c'était il ya dix jours
martin problème que j'ai c'est que là on
dit c'est pour les moins de 25 ans de
sakho qu'est ce qui nous dit que dans
quelques mois on va dire ah bah non les
rafettes s étaient les moins de 65 vous
répondre c'est que tous les cas de
trompes aux graves ont été observés en
europe où les cas parmi les millions de
personnes
c'était des gens de moins de 50 ans
c'est pour ça que le vaccin pourquoi
très probablement parce que c'est un
phénomène immunitaire c'est-à-dire que
c'est une sur réaction de votre système
immunitaire et que le système
immunitaire est plus réactif chez les
jeunes que chez les personnes un peu
plus âgés et donc dans d'extrême rares
cas effectivement le système immunitaire
s'emballe créés probablement cette
thrombose et dans les gares arcas cd
potro moss qui sont graves non mais les
naissances est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que ce jeune peut-être chez jeu
mais bien sûr des guillemets des
conditions conditionnelle il est en
pleine santé
il est dans le nom de domaine médical il
se fait vacciner pour être tranquille et
peut-être ne pas contaminer que
quelqu'un d'autre est quelqu'un qui peut
avoir une qu'ovide dangereuse à
quelqu'un de plus âgé
son grand-père et qu'aujourd'hui il est
décédé
c'est incroyable comment comment vous
pouvez dire derrière c'est vrai que ça
va je le dit et ça me fait
la peine et je trouve que ça veut dire
qu'on va reculer comment vous allez
allez dire à des gens aujourd'hui
faites vous vacciner avec l'astra zeneca
et mais je dirais que de toute façon
plus personne ne se trouve pas dans la
situation de ce jeune homme si tu n'y
aura plus aucun jeune âge on fera
vacciner avec l'astra avec un rendez
compte le recul axa fait c'est à dire
que là c'est une catastrophe ça veut
dire qu'on a misé sur le mauvais vaccins
non ça veut dire si on n'a pas misé sur
le vin 126 extrêmement efficace sûre
chez nous des gens parfaitement raison
de s'inquiéter du vaccin des vaccins
actuellement car ces vaccins n'ont pas
été étudiées correctement ils ont
échappé à tout et une phase normale de
la validation d'un médicament
je vous rappelle qu'un mini bande
d'abord été essayé chez l'animal puis en
phase 1 pour avoir aidé à chelsea puis
en face d'eux que la phase 3 chaque
phase doit succéder aux autres or là
c'est pas du tout le corps les animaux
n'y en avait pas assez il n'y a pas
assez de singer est tellement décès en
cours qu'ils ont arrêté les excès
et comment les essais chez l'animal et
la phase iii n'est pas terminée aucun
vaccin actuellement sur le marché n'a
terminé sa phase iii si vous ne croyez
pas vous regarder sur le site
international américain qui s'appelle
clinique al trial ce point gov
vous pouvez même interrogé en français
ils répondent aussi à la très bien
anglais en tout cas non pas du tout je
veux juger était aussi membre de la
société un bon moi je parle mal anglais
c'est pas le problème
en tout cas s'ils répondent en france
est donc toute personne ici qui est
intéressée peut s'interroger saucier et
vous verrez l'essai il donne la date de
début de l'essai la date de fin des
excès pour le premier kill fiser la date
de fin d'essais c'est fin janvier 2023
pour le l'autre sens le modern à ses 22
février 23 et pour l'astra et nez cassé
et janvier 24 et bien d'autres nous
n'avons pas eu d'essais actuellement
donc il faut s'inquiéter tant que nous
n'avons pas les et c'est pourquoi je me
ferai pas vacciner
on a des résultats transitoire martin
quand vous n'êtes pas quelqu'un qui
connaît bien le développement clinique
la plupart des médicaments des vaccins
qui sont mises sur le marché sont mis
avant que les acétates fondamentales
n'ont quà laissez moi finir souffrait
bagdad géré en espèces il n'existe pas
et moi finir cette journée spes de face
que c'est telle phase d'extension qui
fait qu'on continue de surveiller de
suivre et ça c'est la phase 4 longer
désolé si on est amené c'est la face
gahtani par des conventions de la face
rome leur enseigne les ans que je suis
dans le développement de ces vaccins il
arrive parfois que des médicaments qui
sont mis sur le marché révèlent quand
ils sont utilisés par un très grand
nombre de personnes quelques très rares
cas d'événement secondaire ce qui nous
emmène à revoir l'indication du produit
c'est regrettable pour les quelques
personnes effectivement qu'ils ont subi
c'est un événement indésirable mais ça
arrive tous les jours et marc poulin
médicaments et des vaccins
martin blachier juste question on s'est
dit au départ le finder c'est pour les
personnes plus âgées
la phrase et les cas c'est pour les plus
jeunes on se rend compte aujourd'hui
qu'en fait non le prize heures c'est
pour les plus âgés la stratégie cas
c'est pour les plus âgés
il est à l'interdît l'astra donnez-nous
les 16 50 - l'inquiétude on va revenir
sur la strada n'est qu'à l'inquiétude
que j'ai c'est l'information qui vient
de tomber vous êtes au courant aux états
unis où l'une des agences de santé dit
qu'il ya eu des utilisations
d'information obsolète pour essayer de
prouver les gens tiennent et du médecin
donc ça allait dessus martin vous
répondez quoi parce que et s'il faut 100
made in japan japon japon vous savez on
dit qu'il ya pas eu ces événements en
grande bretagne non mais sur certains
mais juge attendez je vais en grande
bretagne ils ont vacciné 11 millions de
personnes avec la troisième cas il y
appelle ses quatre thrombose pourquoi
parce qu'il a été utilisé dans la
population âgée essentiellement dans la
population des gens qui ont plus de 65
ans dont qu'ils ont pas vu c'est trop
beau ce décès l'utilisation qu'on va en
faire et les études écossaise sur des
centaines de milliers de personnes
montre que l'efficacité sur les formes
sévères
il est de 100 % sur sept cent mille
britannique efficacité il est conseillé
aux plus de 65 ans au départ la strate
histoire est très simple c'est l'unité
de lumière c'était le soir d'un côté et
une des jeunes des agences américaines
de santé aujourd'hui qu'il ay que
astrazeneca pour faire valider sur
vaccins aux états unis à utiliser
informations obsolètes pour aller pour
attester de son efficacité
mais pour répondre à ça je suis
évidemment pas dans le coeur
d'astrazeneca puisque je n'y travaille
pas donc j'ai pas accès aux données et
ses rivales en corse
en revanche j'ai accès aux données
comptes et publié par le gouvernement
anglais cas vacciner 700000 écossais et
qui montrent que la forme est grave elle
est de 100%
ça veut dire que je m'inscris garde fou
oui c'est là dessus
monsieur blaché a raison sur la
communication qui est faite par le
gouvernement anglais mais comme par
hasard mais le gouvernement anglais ne
parle pas des morts depuis la
vaccination les la vaccination a
commencé en angleterre le 4 décembre
nous avons donc plus de 4 3 mois les
mois qui ont suivi la vaccination ont
battu tous les records de mortalité et
de contamination le taux de
contamination quotidienne d'après les
chiffres de l' oms a été multiplié par
trois entre avant là que la crise et
après la vexin dans les trois mois alors
c'est vrai donc a eu beaucoup plus de
morts il ya eu autant de morts dans les
deux mois qui ont suivi la vaccination
que dans tous les mois précédents
l'épidémie c'est colossal
ces gouvernements ne dirigent pas tous
ces sites est ce que quand on voit cette
thrombose c'est ce jeune homme de 24 ans
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter ou est-ce
que la mesure qui a été prise de ne plus
vacciner les moins de 55 ans avec
l'astra zeneca et suffisante alors dans
l'immédiat oui dans l'immédiat oui oui
dans sa lettre d'accord avec marc à me
lâcher attention attention je suis
d'accord qu'un l'asfa dégâts doit pas
être donnée en dessous de 55 ans comme
c'est dit par là deuxièmement
qu'astrazeneca doit pas être donné après
65 ans comme samedi ce sera exactement
les recommandations de la haute autorité
de santé has been rien je suis désolé
mais c'est ce qu'ils avaient dit au
départ c'est écrit alors je serai bon
pourquoi ils ont dit ça parce qu'il y
avait très peu de questions
j'avais plus de 65 ans dans l'express
d'astra des cas 10 depuis là on a eu les
données anglaise où ils ont baptisé
massivement les gens de plus de 65 ans
ils ont bien montré que la réduction de
mortalité était considérable et la
réduction de formes graves étaient aussi
considérable écouter lisez-la public
mais si je l'aï vu de cette publication
je prétend qu'elle est fausse car ne
correspond pas aux résultats de l'om est
juste un jour expliquer ça ils ont parlé
de la mort des martyrs cas aujourd'hui
nous retourne à entre 30 et 50 ans et
qu'on veut se faire et 55 ans et qu'on
espère vacciner on fait quoi
aujourd'hui on attend se fera plus vexe
pour l'instant on n'a pas de vaccination
d'accord vous le dire alors on pourra
utiliser le vaccin de pfizer mêlée
réservé aux 75 ans qui sont priorisées
stratégie qu'elle est bonne aujourd'hui
les personnes plus jeunes ne sera figé
les bonnes la stratégie est bonne il
faut absolument vacciner les personnes
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont en réanimation
c'est des gens qui ont plus de 50 ans
donc il faut massivement vacciner les
gens de plus de 50 ans en commençant par
les personnages et 50 ans cac 40 dont
nous devons dire que j'embrasse
kéké voilà comment ça sans tiers
d'enfants à qui je fais un gros bisou
vous me dire à sa famille aussi
on va s'en sortir mais juste un docteur
de pin est ce que est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter moi c'est une question
opposé nole est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter du coronavirus de l'aco vide
ou est ce que pour vous c'est
on doit pas s'en inquiéter parce que en
vrai ce que vous me disiez off on va pas
se mentir
vous m'avez dit en fait tout ça il
fallait pas s'en inquiéter on s'en
inquiète trop et on prend trop de
mesures c'est ce que vous pensez qu'un
complément passionnément ce bavarois moi
je suis un vieux monsieur on passe à la
dernière partie juste pour ça merci j'ai
connu les études éminemment juste
est ce que vous pensez qu'on en fait
trop assez massivement trop quoi parce
qu'on tue plein de gens par des mesures
ignore mais quand vous voyez des jeunes
comme maintenant dire là qui est passé à
halle à deux doigts de la mort c'est de
la langue belle santé
je dirais c'est de la faute du
gouvernement qui a permis aux médecins
de traiter car on parle que de vaccins
toute cette crise a été montée pour
vendre 15 milliards de vaccins
or quand vous pensez que toute cette
crise la coved c'est pour vendre 15
millions de vaccins et aussi pour mettre
la tyrannie en place car on a habitué
les gens ont peur ça se voit dans la rue
vous notez le nombre de masques vous
avez directement le pourcentage de gens
suisses ont terrorisé je rappelle que
j'ai effectivement 75 ans un peu plus
donc j'ai connu la grippe asiatique la
grippe asiatique
vous l'avez tous oublié un ordi et et on
n'était pas non oui mais bon ben oui
mais il ya des livres
il ya des jours là bas oui vous me dire
ça lui arrive depuis la grippe a décroît
alors oui bon à l'aller pédiatrique a
tué 2 milliards d'individus sur 2
millions de vies de millions d'individus
sur terre
à une époque où la population était
moitié moindre actuel ce qui veut dire
c'est l'équivalent actuellement de 4
millions de personnes
le cabinet qui a deux millions six
actuellement en année le nom médicaux
que parce que si on regarde en nombre
d'années perdues locaux vides ne fait
que comme faisaient tout et grippe
ordinaire tue et les gens qui ont six
mois
donc oui mais ce n'est pas une maladie
épouvantable ce n'est pas la placer moi
je vous aime beaucoup une fois de plus
vous laissera pas de pv pour pour nous
dire une chose mais qui peut-être
peut-être vrai mais on sait les choses
mais attendez
non pas pour avancer il faut laisser les
dopeurs on interdit aux docteurs de
traiter sur de la grippe nous savons
tous même s'il faut les antibiotiques
c'est pas automatique chez les vieux
donner des antibiotiques quand il faut
une grippe ça et protège des infections
bactériennes gouvernement pas interdit
c'est la chloroquine qu'il fallait
donner il fallait je pense donner entre
autres la chloroquine baroque la
chloroquine il fallait aussi donner un
antibiotique car manque de traitements
raoult s'est pas la chloroquine me rate
la chloroquine joue un peu et
l'antibiotique joue beaucoup
docteur docteur révèle juste pour vous
cette crise est elle existe cette
maladie bien entendu c'est une vraie
maladie
tout à fait mais schori mais pourquoi
elle a été pour pourquoi aujourd'hui
vous vous pensez que tout la roue c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement français
prendrait des mesures qui économiquement
pas nouveau mais cette fois lui [ __ ]
entier d'abord main ce n'est pas le
monde entier ce n'est seulement la
moitié est essentiellement les pays
industrialisés qui ont pris ces mesures
je suis désolé et donc c'est les autres
pays par exemple expliquer votre théorie
les téléspectateurs qui n'engage que
vous bien sûr écrit comment votre
théorie bon pour moi c'est très simple
une maladie ça se traite
alors on a refusé on a non seulement
refusé de traiter non plus on a interdit
aux médecins de traiter
il faut remarquer que la chloroquine moi
j'en ai pris quand j'allais en afrique
de manière courante et j'allais chez le
pharmacien ou les données comme ça sans
ordonnance sans rien l'alto rouquine est
un des mes diamants qui a plus de 50 ans
d'existence et wick a traité plusieurs
milliards et il n'y a pas eu d'incident
brutalement on nous raconte c'est un
produit extrêmement dangereux qui tue et
pourquoi pas pour parce que alors on y
arrive pour vendre des vaccins
car la mise actuellement sur le marché
des vaccins ne tient qu'à l'absence de
traitement que je peux répondre juste
une chose assure vaart le vaccin strass
donné qu'à et le vexin johnson effet à
prix coûtant par le laboratoire attend
dès à présent à leur marché
maigre épousé une trop proche du lenn
qui est on sait que le syndic hlm
non les entreprises du médicament
d'accord c'est le syndicat des
entreprises du médicament et donc leur
but c'est de vendre de nouveaux
médicaments chers parce que les vieux
surtout pas alors que poussent travaille
à l'hôpital et les pas du tout il aime
mais bon c'est pas grave c'est votre
gêne ex épouse qui travaille dans un
hôpital mais là il ya une rumeur qui
court que m'a tant que ce serait mon
épouse et qui effective au travail
jusqu'au réponse cette histoire parce
que je veux le dire les choses
oxford a conclu avec astrazeneca il a
dit on travaille avec vous si le vaccin
est disponible à prix coûtant pour le
monde entier c'est effectivement le cas
le laboratoire johnsen a eu beaucoup de
financements de la part de l'état
américain
entre autres et ils vendent le vaccin à
prix coûtant voilà donc c'est pas pour
faire de l'argent qu'astrazeneca
commercial et ce mec là puisqu'ils le
font à prix coûtant ils n'ont que des
coups à prendre si lens est en train à
très juste
cette thrombose ce jeune homme vraiment
et cette affaire qui a bouleversé tout
le monde qu'est ce qui fait que ce
vaccin astrazeneca donne des thromboses
on ne sait pas exactement le mécanisme
déjà passé c'est que ça promet pas
certain aujourd'hui que ces vaccins
donne d'être aux côtés avec de très
rares personnes à ces jeunes car ils
avaient fait des thromboses grave après
avoir reçu le vaccin
non mais attendez je vous donne et fait
travailler deuxièmement on ne connaît
pas le mécanisme il c'est possible que
ce soit un mécanisme qui soit laid
l'immunité des gens qui reçoivent le
vaccin qui réagissent très fort parce
qu'ils ont un système immunitaire
vigoureux et il ya des phénomènes de
coagulation secret qu'ils sont c'est à
travers ce qui bon ça fait qu'on devait
exprimer mes jeunes ça n'arrive jamais
chez les gens pour l'église est gentil
flip qui
pour expliquer ce qu'est assez je
comprends qu'il y ait des gens de chez
rien dit sur votre tente quelque chose
de jute aboa bongo que je vous libère
monsieur délépine est ce que vous pouvez
expliquer aux téléspectateurs vous votre
votre théorie sur toute cette histoire
toute cette épidémie tout cette pandémie
c'est vraiment d'amy est donc une une
grippe un peu plus mauvaise que
d'habitude du même ordre que la grippe
asiatique pour lequel on n'a pas confiné
on a en a pas encore merdé le peuple un
joli accord et on n'allait quand même
pas pourquoi on emmerde le peuple a pour
plusieurs raisons 1 parce qu'il ya une
crise financière qu'ils quand même est
colossal et qui donc actuellement les
grandes banques ne savent pas comment
s'en sortir
donc quoi ils sont dit on va on va
lancer des noms ce pauvre con lancé la
pandémie la pandémie est arrivé nous
fait actuellement le même coup qu'on a
essayé de nous faire pour la chaîne
je vous rappelle que pour a h1n1 nous
avait dit c'est terrible le ministre a
dit il faut absolument il ya des jeunes
qui sont en train de mourir à faire et
c'était est conçu comme une grippe est
en fait enfin d'acteurs enfin de trucs
là la chaîne à debout tu es beaucoup
moins de français que les grippe
ordinaire bon et là on nous refait le
même coup on a une grippe qui n'a pas
été créée par les économistes ni lui ni
par les big pharmas j'allais absous
absolument de ce péché mais qui étaient
utilisées et sûr utilisé et dont on a
créé nice quand j'entends le virus est
un être malins qui des journaux enfin le
virus est pas un être faut arrêter il
pense pas est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
des variants pas du tout les variants
bas c'est une histoire naturelle les
virus à arn puisque c'est un virus à arn
samut souvent à chaque mutation
l'invariant la règle générale je dis
bien général je suis pas prophète chez
pas ce qui arrivera dans trois mois
valait la règle générale c'est plus un
virus mute plus il devient contagieux et
- devient dangereux voilà en échange sa
nacelle a rain vient pas on sait jamais
on ne sait jamais à quelle heure sonne
enfin sauf ferguson qui a promis que si
on ne fermait pas du sun rappeler que
c'est celui qui a certainement titien
monsieur me lâcher doit être très bien
connecté un conseiller emmanuel macron
oui mais qui n promis qu'ils auraient
par exemple pas le freineur de match à
lorient et nantes
c'est neil ferguson du l'impérial
collège qui avaient promis qu'ils
restent cinq cent mille morts en france
et mâcon à tripper alors on va regarder
ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs oui à
70%
non à 30% c'est normal voilà le résultat
il est complètement normal avec ce qui
s'est passé bien